[Musique]
ne me paye pas assez pour faire les deux, donc en
guise de protestation, je vais juste
vivre à mon travail et nous verrons combien de temps je
pourrai m'en sortir avec ça
Je suis à Seattle et Seattle est l'un des
des villes plus chères aux États-Unis.
Quand j'ai déménagé ici, je ne pouvais me
permettre qu'un appartement de 100 pieds carrés qui
coûtait environ treize cents dollars. C'est
une boîte bienvenue dans mon studio.  le
loyer augmentait de
trois cents dollars
et c'était je suis comme 300 pour ça pour le
petit petit endroit
qui est à peu près à l'époque où j'ai découvert que
mon bureau avait un bureau au centre-ville et
c'était ce bel espace mais c'était Big
Empty à cause de covid  et euh c'est
quand j'étais comme quand j'ai découvert que je
n'obtenais pas d'évaluation de performance,
découvert que je n'obtenais pas d'augmentation, j'étais
comme parfait, nous allons au centre-ville et
c'était un endroit parfait aussi
[Musique]
oh c'est là  J'ai dormi c'est bien d'avoir
mes tissus parce que je fais des vêtements
parfois j'ai tous mes livres le
réfrigérateur était complètement vide alors j'ai
apporté mon repas signature que mon
principal repas qui est du jambon et de l'ananas
j'ai acheté une centaine de dollars
et j'ai tout mis dans le  le réfrigérateur avait un
cuiseur à riz alors j'ai juste apporté les
cuiseurs à riz ils avaient déjà du thé ils avaient
du café gratuit tout ce qui est parfait et
le deuxième bâtiment nous avons une douche pour hommes
dans la salle de bain d'accord nous avons
des serviettes et nous avons deux douches allez
maintenant je  a pensé que ça bébé
étranger
mardi c'est devenu viral mercredi
ils l'ont su mercredi et ils m'ont
contacté jeudi ils étaient comme
tu sais tu vis hors du
bureau et pour moi j'étais comme d'accord tu
sais alors je nie nier jusqu'à  vous savez
jusqu'à ce que nous découvrions ce qui se passe, ils
étaient comme ouais d'accord,
peu importe ce qui est vrai ou faux, nous avons
besoin que vous supprimiez vos objets personnels
du bureau euh nous avons besoin que vous supprimiez
les vidéos euh
nous examinerons si oui ou non  nous ne pouvons pas
vous donner une évaluation ou une mesure de performance pour
voir si vous êtes payé au
taux du marché pour le poste en quelque sorte expliqué
qu'il était comme si cela nous faisait mal paraître que
nous ayons quelqu'un
euh que nous ayons la situation et puis
nos employés  pourrait finir par se sentir mal
[Musique]
devrais-je supprimer
eh bien, j'avais déjà commencé à rechercher des
opportunités d'emploi et j'avais déjà
passé des entretiens à différents endroits en
retournant dans une entreprise qui ne me payait pas
assez ne l'a pas fait  ne me respecte pas assez
pour me faire un bilan de performance quand j'en ai
demandé un ou quand je vous sais quand j'en
attendais un comme c'est courant au bout d'un
an et qu'on me l'a dit lors de la
phase d'entretien
plutôt que de retourner dans une entreprise qui
ne me respecte pas,
je viens d'être expulsé
cet inconnu mais j'ai des options infernales ou
vous connaissez quelqu'un qui ne
me respecte plus comme c'était C'était plutôt
facile ouais je veux dire euh ça ne volerait pas dans
la plupart des lieux de travail mais c'est le  point
j'espère que vos employés ne se sentent pas obligés
de faire des conneries pour économiser de l'argent
[Musique]
mon expérience m'a appris que
ce système que nous avons créé est
fait pour maximiser les
profits de l'investissement  cela est mis
en place et souvent, surtout à mesure que
les entreprises deviennent de plus en plus grandes, la
partie humaine de cela est minimisée si vous
voulez que quelque chose change dans votre vie,
vous devez faire ce changement parce que
personne d'autre ne le donne, il se soucie de
vous, vous devez faire  ça change pour
toi